Ils nous intoxiquent
ça fait 4 jours que je respire dans mon t-shirt pour pas que ça m'empoisonne
Ah vous êtes pas au courant ? Ah tient donc !
Eh bien bienvenue dans cette vidéo théorie du complot
Quatrième ou cinquième du nom dans laquelle vous apprendrez que les avions
lâchent des gaz toxiques
le sujet est génial parce que je trouvais ça ridicule
presque comme la terre plate et je me suis documenté à mort et maintenant je trouve ça moins
ridicule j'suis pas là pour dire si c'est vrai ou pas comme d'habitude
blablabla ici insérer un discours politiquement correct pour désamorcer tout ce qui va suivre
si vous connaissez on va en venir au fait très rapidement avez vous entendu parler des chemtrails ?
ouais j'ai travaillé mon accent anglais look above your head
là j'en ai trop fait.
alors je vous apprends rien en vous disant que les avions dans le ciel laissent une traînée derrière eux
ce truc là c'est tout simplement la condensation de la vapeur d'eau que va émettre le moteur quand il est en route à haute altitude
uniquement parce qu'il fait froid très froid
êtes  vous sûr qu'il s'agit bien de traînées de condensation ?
et non pas d'un produit que le gouvernement lâche en cachette sur la population j'avoue être
secrètement fans de cette théorie vraiment les amis on se calme déjà
commençons par le début alors cette théorie contrairement à ce qu'on croit il ya vraiment beaucoup de gens qui y croient beaucoup plus que de gens
qui croient à la terre plate d'ailleurs la différence c'est qu'il y a énormément de gens qui rejoignent le groupe de la "flat earth society " juste pour se
moquer d'eux vraiment alors que là j'ai regardé c'est essentiellement des gens qui y  croient vraiment et qui défendent le truc
en tout cas on allume tous notre esprit critique pendant cette vidéo c'est parti on y va on parlait des traînées derrière les avions pour
ces gens quand je dis ces gens je parle de ceux qui sont convaincus que les chemtrails existe il y a deux types de traînées
derrière les avions il y a les contrails c'est la condensation de la vapeur d'eau qui sort des moteurs comme j'ai dit au début de
vidéo il y aller chemtrails "chem" comme "chemicals" qui veut dire chimique une traînée chimique alors n'y a pas de
preuves tangibles
ya juste des photos qui montrent des grosses traînées derrière des avions et pour ces gens ces traînées là c'est pas de la condensation à
ce stade là c'est quelque chose qui est lancé volontairement dans l'air par les avions en plus de la condensation que l'avion peut faire, certaines personnes
ont remarqué aussi que quand ils étaient  plus jeunes et qu'ils regardaient le ciel ils voyaient des avions et il ne voyaient pas de traînées  derrière eux alors que maintenant
effectivement dès que tu vois un avion dans le ciel ben il y a une putain de traînée derrière lui quoi et plus il est haut plus la
traînée est grosse et ces gens il expliquent ça part la volonté du gouvernement de balancer quelque chose dans l'atmosphère mais dans quel but
pourquoi vous faites ça gouvernement
alors à partir de là il ya plusieurs théories parce qu'ils ne savent pas exactement
pourquoi ils font ça on va commencer par les plus tranquilles pour aller au plus vénères c'est plusieurs théories dans une seule théorie du complot
je trouve çà génial premièrement il pense que ce serait peut-être dans le but de contrôler la météo pour mieux se défendre c'est un avantage s'il
y a une fight à un moment où une embrouille j'ai d'ailleurs appris qu'on était capable d'ensemencer un nuage de manière à
provoquer la pluie plus rapidement je ne savais pas mais apparemment c'est déjà utilisé en chine pour augmenter les
précipitations dans les zones touchées par la sécheresse en gros on va envoyer une roquette sur le nuage
hyper violent dans laquelle il y a entre autres des cristaux d'iodure d'argent
j'ai aucune idée des propriétés de ce truc là en tout cas ça a provoqué une pluie ce serait aussi utilisé pour empêcher le brouillard dans les
aéroports ou
empêcher des chutes de grosse grêle pouvant endommager ce qu'il y a en dessous dans les villes ou endommager même les gens sachant ça ça paraît donc
crédible que le gouvernement soit capable d'envoyer des produits chimiques dans l'air dans le but de contrôler la météo après je vois pas pourquoi ce
serait du coup un truc secret ils pourraient totalement nous dire pas de problème surtout que ça nous arrange de passe prendre de la grêle
monumentale sur la gueule deuxième théorie qui elle aussi est plutôt gentille
peut-être que le gouvernement est bienveillant il
lâcherait un mélange chimique dans le but de dévier le rayonnement solaire faut lutter contre le réchauffement climatique
et l'appauvrissement de la couche d'ozone en gros les rayons du soleil
repartiraient vers l'espace au lieu de toucher la couche d'ozone et la Terre ça me paraît un peu gros mais ok on n'est pas là
pour valider ou pas une théorie on est juste là pour prendre connaissance de ces théories et
peut-être dire s'il y en a des plus connes que d'autres après y'a pas d'alors y a des tas de photos
montrant des intérieurs d'avions avec beaucoup de bonbonnes qui contiennent des produits
et on se dit putain cet avion a dû lâcher un truc dans l'air notamment quand il y a des incendies surtout Californie à des avions qui passent
au dessus et qui sont équipés pour
lâcher un produit dans l'air en l'occurrence des produits qui ont pour but d'éteindre le feu mais il pourrait utiliser la même technologie pour lâcher
des produits pas dans le but d'éteindre les feux
troisième théorie et là on rentre dans les théories qui sont pour moi les
plus plausibles si la théorie du complot et si il y a vraiment chemtrails je serai plus pour ces raisons là que pour des trucs gentils ou
alors ils nous l'auraient dit je pense ce serait Monsanto qui serait derrière ce lâcher de produits chimiques dans l'atmosphère
Monsanto qui est une boîte qui a entre autres fait des pesticides est à l'origine des OGM
voilà vous avez vu sur dans les médias le débat autour du glyphosate et même si Monsanto nous dit que ce produit n'est pas
du tout nocif pour l'Homme il y a des tas de
témoignages de gens qui ont eu des cancers qui sont morts après avoir utilisé ce produit là pendant des années dans leur chambre bref ces lâchés
de produits chimiques auraient pour but de détruire les plantations sauf que les céréales modifiées génétiquement comme ceux que propose Monsanto
résisteraient à cette tombée de produits chimiques donc tous les agriculteurs au sol voyant leurs plantations
pourrir et mourir se tourneraient vers Monsanto pour leur acheter leurs OGM qui eux résisteraient à ces tombées
il y a vraiment des putains de
crapules des voyous dans ce monde donc en vrai un truc comme ça me paraît même pas impossible quoi et maintenant la théorie la plus connue
celle que ces gens croient le plus et je comprends parce que c'est la plus violente de toutes ils lâcheraient un
mélange de métaux lourds dans l'atmosphère plus précisément un mélange d'aluminium de baryum et de strontium qui sont des trucs très mauvais pour la santé
et le gouvernement lâcherait ses cocktails nocives dans l'atmosphère dans le but d'augmenter les maladies au sol et donc
l'espérance de vie et donc de combattre la surpopulation. Ah mais du coup c'est pour notre bien
Ah chemtrails ! je trouve qu'il y a des moyens un peu moins abusés de combattre la surpopulation comme par exemple y a eu en Chine
quand ils ont réduit le taux de fertilité et qu'ils ont limité à 1 le nombre d'enfants possibles par couple
alors éthiquement parlant c'est un peu chaud de faire ça mais en vrai c'est moins chaud que juste de balancer du gaz pour tuer les
gens et créer des maladies
voilà les quatre possibilités de pourquoi le gouvernement lâcherait les chemtrails, si chemtrails il y a je vous rappelle c'est pas du tout prouvé
alors tout ça c'est bien beau ça fait rêver mais maintenant
rationalisons un peu tout ça
premièrement si la majorité des avions était vraiment équipé pour lâcher des produits chimiques en plein vol ça veut dire que tous les mecs qui
bossent dans un aéroport les mécanos les pilotes ceux qui mettent les bagages en soute, ceux qui
entretiennent l'avion tous ces gens là feraient partie du complot c'est quand même un peu abusé deuxièmement ces traînées elles ont lieu quand l'avion est
très très haut dans ciel et donc avant d'atteindre le sol mon gars elle se tape du vent mais pendant des heures donc elles n'atterriraient pas
du tout là où le gouvernement voudrait qu'elles atterrissent y aurait une trajectoire un peu
aléatoire vu comme elle serait soumise aux vents et du coup serait pas du tout les effets escomptés par le gouvernement puisque ça tombe pas
au bon endroit sauf il est vrai si le but est vraiment d'affaiblir les gens et de le rendre un peu teubé, au quel cas
on s'en fout de là où ça tombe tant que ça tombe sur des gens alors que d'habitude je propose de regarder quelques vidéos pour
conclure cette vidéo là de manière à voir si les arguments de ces gens sont tangibles
Plus que 3724 jours avant la retraite allez tu peux le faire patrick
Car c'est de la condensation ! Souffle sur ta fenêtre un soir d'hiver tu vas voir...
Mais ce cadreur gros, les chemtrails çà lui a flinguer le cerveau le mec , regarde comment il cadre ! Il a sniffé du chemtrail il est allé au
cul de l'avion il a fait ça (renifle)
ouah, y a des vidéos de gens qui check dans le ciel les avions qui ont des traînées normales et les autres des traînées de chemtrails une
très grosse traînée qui est en cours avec un largage qui est en cours là-bas,
un largage qui est en cours ici un autre qui arrive
ahlala il a plein d'avions qui passe au dessus de chez lui et surtout ça qui est impressionnant gros attends mais il y a une piste
d'atterrissage dans son jardin là ou quoi voilà ce monsieur ah oui j'ai oublié de parler de ça apparemment les chemtrails ils laisseraient des petits filaments semblables
à des toiles d'araignées quand ils atterrissent au sol le film de chemtrail lui n'a aucune résistance, il est complètement élastique
Au lieu de prélever des chemtrails, paye tes factures, gros. Là vraiment tu as une mise en demeure qui est juste à droite tu peux
pas laisser ça au montage quoi faut faire un truc !
Oh putain attendez là on a un pilote qui parlent enfin.
Joe qu'est ce qui nous dit que tu ne fais pas partie du complot et que tu essaies pas de nous convaincre du contraire, hein ?
Mais ouais t'es en train de cacher le fait que ça balance des chemtrails par le bout des ailes c'est tout ce qu'on voit
ici joe
Tellement fake !
Alors Joe tu dis quoi la
Bah bien sûr que ça aurait du sens justement parce que du coup tu peux dire "bas on ferait pas çà, çà aurait pas de sens !" alors que si vous le faites vous êtes malins
Mec c'est génial qu'il relie ça aux pesticides quoi.
Il montre le vrai problème : regardez le
Je l'aime, je vous jure, j'adore Joe. Il est trop cool !
J'espère que tu piloteras l'avion qui m'emmènera à l'E3
Attendez y a Elisa Batour qui intervient, attendez.
(lit le commentaire youtube)
"Il se fout carrément de nous avec son titre menteur ils pensent que nous sommes les moutons
qui ignorent qu'il nous conduit par la main ! Il est carrément stupide ce soit disant pilote (l'habit ne fait pas le moine n'oublions pas ça)"
Écoute Joe, j'ai vu clair dans ton jeu tout ce que tu dis c'est des foutaises
Aujourd'hui il nous faut un leader, il faut quelqu'un pour changer ce monde.
Pour prouver que les chemtrails existent vraiment et les réduire à néant
Attendez c'est le grand prophète c'est lui
c'est michel delmeau
(lit les commentaires)
"Il faut avertir le grand public, les amis !"
"et si on y allait en groupe, on rentre à Orly par exemple, on passe derrière, on trouve la salle de repos des pilotes on
voit lesquels font ce job là et on leur colle des baffes jusqu'à ce qu'ils jurent de ne plus recommencer ?"
Oh putain elle est la solution !
Elle est là, bravo Michel !
Bon les amis, on rigole, on rigole, mais c'est la fin de la vidéo.
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu,
Attention à ne pas croire tout ce que vous lisez sur
Internet. Je parle pas de tout ceux qui parlent de chemtrails, je parle juste de témoignages un peu bidons, de preuves vraiment fausses comme le
bouton là, la photo du bouton c'est nul c'est honteux
Quoi qu'il en soit, j'adore cette théorie
J'espère n'avoir froissé personne comme d'habitude et si vous croyez aux chemtrails
sachez que je vous respecte, vous avez sûrement de très bonnes raisons d'y croire,
Mais attention à ce que vous lisez. Plus vous êtes jeunes logiquement, plus vous êtes
influençables,
C'est normal je l'étais aussi énormément pendant un moment.
Et quand tu grandis que ton esprit critique grandit aussi tu te rends compte de
certains trucs et tu fais attends mais non en fait !
En tout cas, moi je me casse à Los Angeles après cette vidéo.
Enfin
au moment où vous la voyez je serai quasiment déjà revenu ;
mais je vous fais plein de bisous
A très vite il y a mon avion qui m'attend
Oh putain, un chemtrail oh putain (tousse et s'étouffe)
(musique)